I'm wanting to get up to this summer in
LA well I trunk you away from people
like you I try to avoid giving
interviews it is said that I like the
odd drink I like watching cricket though
the Lord's Test match was a little bit
depressing and I shall lock next week we
often going drunk catch a fish so on has
come today said that there's no
negativity in this coming weekend have
to act upon conservative and not getting
that thing you are going out of
campaigning you think it's going to play
some badminton what actually actually
you know you will have seen in national
newspaper columns this week a shedload
of abuse thrown at me by some of these
people I'm not throwing it back I'm
urging them I'm urging them if you
believe in what we're trying to do
please get up off your backside come and
help us come and share the platform with
us I couldn't be more open or friendly
than that
of course I don't believe the divisions
have left and right I mean a bloomin
thing compared to whether we have our
own democracy and the self governance of
our own nation I would be very happy to
share a stage with those guys if they
would with me well let's wait and see
why not you know if this referendum is
tight then we're going to need to bring
together all the forces that we possibly
can and don't forget we're going to be
up against the establishment we're going
to be up against the big corporates
we're going to be up against the ruling
class of this country I think one of the
shifts has been that the left have begun
to woke need really wake up to what the
European Union is I think many people
who would who would call themselves
democratic socialists are just mortified
at the way Greece has been treated in
the wake of a referendum that said to
the government you must not do this
thing I think that's woken people up
I've also noticed as an MEP how to eat
it has suddenly woken up the left uma
trade unions as so many of the things
that have been done in our name that are
not being debated or put through our own
Parliament you know if you're a Democrat
it doesn't matter whether you're on the
been aight wing of politics you know or
whether you're on a sort of conservative
right-wing end of politics if you
believe in democracy then you should
come together on this no campaign
way about the general election what
you're saying have changed that what you
think all may know now that I've been so
hard to government your message exam
dates do i think being self-governing
and democratic and being able to control
your own borders and make your own trade
deals around the world and to be free to
re-engage with the commonwealth and all
of your friends if that's out of date
we're all finished